hey listen to this this is just a
pleasure to read
rudy giuliani is being sued by dominion
voting systems over
false election claims the lawsuit
against rudy giuliani
is because he is accused of carrying out
a quote viral disinformation campaign
dominion voting systems has filed a
defamation lawsuit the lawsuit was filed
this morning and it's 107 pages long it
accuses
not only giuliani as i mentioned of
carrying out a viral disinformation
campaign
about dominion it accuses him of uh
putting out their demonstrably false
allegations to enrich himself through
legal fees and his podcast and that's
true
a big theme on his popular podcast for
rudy giuliani was
making false claims about dominion
voting systems
the suit is suing rudy for 1.3
billion dollars yeah they're not going
to get that i know
uh and it makes um these uh
it files this suit on the basis of 50
different statements that rudy made
at legislative hearings via tweets as
well as on his podcast and while being
interviewed on conservative news media
now as you know
rudy giuliani um was supposedly getting
20 grand a day to defend donald trump or
represent donald trump in the election
fraud
bogus cases we later learned that donald
trump
directed his team not to pay rudy
giuliani and we don't know
if for how much of that 20 grand a day
rudy has actually been able to collect
but look at this does anybody feel sorry
for rudy
you throw your reputation away to peddle
baseless conspiracy theories for trump
which of course go nowhere trump ends up
saying
don't pay him and now rudy is going to
accumulate
significant legal fees because he's
getting sued for the things that he said
now
he should be sued he should be disbarred
and in the end he uh should be held
accountable
for his role in the insurrection which
now i don't just mean
on the day of the insurrection saying
let's do trial by combat that's bad
enough
but i mean the two and two months that
he spent
ginning up anger over non-existent voter
fraud claims with his hearings and his
flatulence at the hearings and
everything else and you can actually
make the case that dominion voting
systems
has really been irreparably damaged by
the false allegations
it is hard to think of a time where i
would take the side of a corporation
against an individual
but the dominion voting system's name
any election that dominion voting
systems is involved in
you are going to have people who come
out of the woodwork and claim fraud
because of dominion voting systems
these people rudy giuliani and sydney
powell
and and lynn wood and whoever they
really have
destroyed the reputation of dominion
voting systems for no reason whatsoever
so
we'll see what happens uh in these
lawsuits
in terms of rudy listen um
a lot of people continue to say rudy was
just compromised that's why rudy did all
of these things
he was compromised we don't yet know the
full extent or the details but he was
if borat can get rudy into the position
rudy found himself in
there's no doubt that professionals
would be able to manipulate rudy
giuliani there's no question about that
and um when you think about it a lot of
the actions from some of these
republicans
can be explained by them being
compromised i'm not saying
they are but for example lauren bobert
owed or owes money to the irs
that would often prevent people from
getting a security clearance
but politicians are still able to run
and get elected regardless
and it puts her in a position of being
very easy to have over a barrel
if the right people get involved rudy
again rudy throwing away his reputation
had strong favorability as
the mayor of new york city after 9 11.
and
that went away over the following years
and then just
completely imploding in terms of his
reputation
during the presidency of donald trump
now by the way
this should be exciting news for anybody
who still believes there was evidence of
election fraud this lawsuit what do i
mean by that
if the lawsuit goes forward the
evidence that rudy giuliani and his
cronies
supposedly have about dominion voting
systems
would come out in the discovery phase of
the lawsuit so for those of you and i
know that there are some of you still in
my audience who think
any day now the evidence will come out
this lawsuit against rudy
is the perfect opportunity to get all of
that evidence of voter fraud out during
the discovery phase
i'll be waiting i look forward to seeing
if we ever see that information
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video